let's jump into this first story we've
got from the Jerusalem Post Russian
strikes hit hits German diplomatic
office in Kiev report the German Embassy
in Kiev was hit by Russian airstrikes on
Monday German media Outlet build
reported however the building has not
been in use since the war broke out the
foreign Ministry said russian-born
journalists and political scientist
Sergey some Lemmy probably not in that
room now based in Berlin tweeted about
the attack asking for Chancellor Olaf
Schultz and other German officials to
issue a response to the airstrike so
okay they've not been using it but this
is still this is if this is the German
Embassy this is German territory right
so what does this mean does this mean
that Germany is now going to use this as
some kind of Castle's belly declare war
or is it is it meaningless well
specifically it was their Visa office
and it looked like a lot of these
strikes weren't for their intended
targets there's one inside of a
playground when Russia of course was
making a speech saying that this was
specific strategic attacks against the
infrastructure of Ukraine uh the the
German Embassy isn't really
infrastructure of Ukraine but there's a
lot of other things happening behind the
scenes I don't think Germany is going to
be doing anything with this I I think
Germany right now also is having a major
bullet shortage I I think that also is
something we should be keeping a close
eye on but there's a lot of other things
happening with Belarus right now with
Poland telling their citizens to leave
Belarus right now Poland is also
checking their uh bunkers right now to
make to make sure that they're up and
running and that they're running
properly so a lot of other things are
happening and this is just episode one
according to the former Ukrainian
president Medvedev of many episodes to
come when it comes to these larger
strikes that Russia is going to be
launching on Ukraine I will mention this
from the reporting they're trying to
make it seem like you know so Germany
condemns you know Russia's actions in
Ukraine then all of a sudden there's an
airstrike some one one of the strikes
happen at a German Embassy and now
Germany is set to deliver air defense
system uh to Ukraine within days
according to the defense Ministry so uh
Reuters reporting Germany will deliver
the first of four Iris tslm air defense
systems to Ukraine within days
and well there you go that's it
I don't I think what we've seen from
NATO for the most part has just been
acting like they're not involved but
basically supplying the overwhelming
majority of weapons strategy
intelligence everything and then you
even have volunteers now we do know last
week this was reported by The Intercept
that U.S Special uh operations are
underway in Ukraine so at what point is
this just world war three
well there's a big concern that the
escalation will continue and and it's
it's kind of odd but the worse it gets
for Putin uh the worse it really gets
for for U.S security because he is a
he's losing the war clearly doing poorly
prospects aren't good for him so he's a
desperate uh dictator and he doesn't
want to get killed off knocked out of
power so he's got to change the
situation and to do that he's got to do
one of a couple things he could use
nuclear weapons in the Ukraine I don't
think it would escalate I think it would
destroy a lot of Ukrainian forces but
there is a risk that you know it could
go to not just using them on the
battlefield but using them near the
border where the supplies are coming in
from Poland and Germany and U.S
equipment coming in that gets close to
New to Nato territory and risks that we
might get involved but more likely and I
think more threatening for the United
States uh is Putin If he if he doesn't
he gets into any nuclear exchange with
the US he loses from that we would
severely hurt him we'd of course be
massively damaged but it would hurt
Russia tremendously so I think he's more
likely to do something like release a
virus clandestinely in the United States
and West Europe something that's not
like covid something like human human
transmissible avian flu 60 lethal highly
transmissible and at that point 60 avian
flu if a human gets avian flu it's not
directly transmissible now but they have
your tax dollars were used and gain of
function research to develop human to
human transmissible mammal to mammal
transmissible versions of avian flu
which is 60 lethal to humans and if he
releases that virus and the way to do
that was published in open source
literature a decade ago and so if Russia
releases a human human transmissible
form of avian flu it'll spread like mad
and at that point who cares about
Ukraine we're trying to stay alive over
here it would be an absolute collapse
situation in the United States already
who cares about Ukraine we're trying to
survive over here I mean the economies
in in shambles we've got Biden they're
sending tons of money off to Ukraine
most Americans can't even point to it on
a map and we're wondering why it is we
are actively involved in a border
dispute with Russia and Ukraine yeah I
kind of have a little different
perspective than than you drew just a
little bit because I I think we're in
the stage where not all options have
been kind of used here I think this
conflict is going to be going back and
forth now with the winter coming to
Ukraine a lot of the forces are going to
be stalled and I think it's going to be
like that for a very long time I think
the the concept of of uh Kissinger
limited Perpetual war is something that
we truly face the reality of and I see
Putin having a lot more options at the
table before going nuclear before even
going bio weapon uh before even going
you know full crazy Mad Men as people
describe them in the media uh before
doing that I I think there's other
Conventional Weapons of war that he
could release there's other attacks he
could do on the Ukrainian infrastructure
and I think he's is going to be using
those methods first even though the
threat of nuclear war is serious but I
think it's it's less probable than a
more aggravated bigger escalation on the
ground from my perspective I don't think
Putin's yet begun to fight I think we've
what we've seen it's like ground forces
in the East now with these missile
strikes over over Ukraine
I think if Putin wanted to he could
unleash substantially more destruction
on the country if he really felt he had
yeah like what we did in Afghanistan and
Iraq was nowhere near even an inkling of
the capability we had of Destruction
because we didn't want to destroy it we
wanted to conquer it and he doesn't want
to destroy Ukraine he wants to conquer
it or at least eastern Ukraine yeah well
General Petraeus was on recently saying
that you know he he thinks that Russia
is in an absolute no-win situation there
and it's getting worse for them and I
tend to agree with that assessment that
Russia has clearly lost this war in a
conventional fight then mobilizing isn't
going to do anything near term and their
their troops just are not motivated for
understandable reasons they're not
defending Russian Homeland they're
invading another country and so the
situation is bad for food it's also
horrible for him on the home front bad
things are going on there so I think he
could now already be in a desperate
situation but he's not going to be
desperate he's a smart ruthless evil man
so he's not going to do something
desperate like launch a nuclear strike
on in the United States that would be
incredibly stupid he is not stupid he's
brilliantly ruthless evil so I think
he's far more likely to do is release a
clandestine bio attack on the United
States that's the smart what's the
overview what's the over under for small
tackle small tactical nuclear weapon
what's the betting odds for in your
opinion for this bio weapon what do you
think is most likely by percentage uh I
think if he's the smartest most
effective thing he could do would be to
get a distraction that takes Ukraine off
the map and gets our support both the
U.S and the Western European support
eliminated quickly and you know what he
did over the weekend well he's got more
now more Western Arms coming into the
Ukraine that doesn't really help him
doesn't change the bad military
situation for him he needs to knock us
out of providing support to Ukraine and
our politicians aren't going to back
down that would look bad it's too much
comparisons to Chamberlain in World War
II so he's got to do something different
and drastic and the way to do it is a
clan destined again not a not an overt
but a clandestine release of a bio
weapon and they've absolutely got all
kinds of viruses smallpox you name it
they've got it but so they release it
over here and you know we are not going
to be sending arms to Ukraine certainly
I do more military forces into NATO if
we're dealing with the pandemic that's
killing off our population and worse
it's unleashing loss of Law and Order as
people are trying to survive and you've
got massive marauding going on across
the United States and millions dying
from that how do you if Putin were to
release a virus what's to stop Russia
from getting hit by it eventually it
would spread but it slid a lot more
slowly if they release it over here not
a whole lot of Air flight going into
Russia right now from the United States
or Western Europe they're already
effectively isolated and the other
person who could do this is the North
Korean dictator he's another person you
know he's at the bottom rank of
effective good places you know power
powerful Nations if there's a pandemic
worldwide great place to be would be
North Korea you don't have you don't
have international travel you you know
you got you know everyone else now gets
destroyed we could lose most of our
population Western Europe most of that
everyone else comes down in power and
Prestige and North Korea Now isn't so
much at the bottom uh they're a country
that survived the Miss I'd rather be in
North Korea than South Korea when
there's an international pandemic of
Eevee and flu spreading but what people
sometimes don't take into account is
clean water the ability to wash yourself
with soap and clean water and how that
can help you overcome a disease so like
people in North Korea that are are
literally sometimes eating other people
because they're starving might be end up
being much sicker from a disease even if
it's there's less of a load in the
environment because they don't have
access to the same kind of treatments
that we do correct but if that virus
kills off most of South Korea and North
Korea can evade it they can now take
South Korea after the viruses died out
when the people are dead
is there anything you're seeing from an
intelligence report that suggests that
there's a probability that this is going
to happen and again what's the
probability from zero to 100 that you
think this is going to happen well I'm a
Former Intelligence officer so nothing I
say tonight will be a release of
classified information in terms of
probability I mean Nasim Talib wrote the
most important valuable book I've ever
read in my life the Black Swan the
influence of the highly improbable and
he trains you not to talk in
probabilities how can I talk about the
probability of something that's never
happened before there's no statistical
evidence for me to use so it's you know
it's expert guesstimation is the honest
term for it but you know you can reason
from people from past situations and
Putin former KGB agent an absolutely
ruthless man you know he knows about the
power of bioweapons they've had him in
the Soviet Union they're biological
weapons program the Soviet Union had
like 60 to 80 000 people working in it
they developed all kinds of agents and
and we in the United States continue to
do as I said gain a function research
where we demonstrate it and then
published the results on how to create a
mammal to mammal contagious we were
using ferrets version of avian flu 60
lethality and we published it thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there